élise avait deux bords dont la suisse
sur le terrain au soutien des
associations qui militent pour inscrire
lives et j'ai comme un droit fondamental
dans notre constitution cécile 6e jugé
trop technocrate pas assez politique la
première ministre semble avoir entendu
les critiques à son encontre
désormais elle occupe le terrain et
multiplie les interventions sur les
sujets qui préoccupent les français
comme la constitutionnalisation de l'ibg
la chef du gouvernement a rencontré ce
matin les associations planning familial
et défendu ce droit fondamental
c'est vraiment un combat qui va falloir
continuer de mener et quand on voit la
fragilité des reculs auquel on peut
assister aujourd'hui y compris en europe
avec l'extrême droite qui remet en cause
ce droit à l'avortement on voit
l'importance d'inscrire ce droit comme
un droit fondamental
autre front le climat cet après midi
elle a reçu à matignon le haut conseil
pour le climat qui lui a remis son
rapport
enfin elisabeth bornes tente de rassurer
sur le terrain politique sans majorité
absolue mais conforté comme première
ministre elle est sous pression pour
former un gouvernement d'action par le
président thein république et mène
depuis deux jours des consultations avec
les chefs de partis politiques les
désaccords semble peu probable il n'a
jamais été question pour nous de rentrer
gouvernement nous portons des
propositions nous avons ce que j'appelle
une culture politique qui consiste à
travailler sur les textes qui nous sont
soumis à voter ce qui peut aller dans le
bon sens il ya des points qui vont dans
le bon sens à s'opposer fermement à ce
qui est régressif ou ce qui est
insuffisant c'est notre culture
politique non pas de changer aujourd'hui
elizabeth donne doit donner sa feuille
de route pour former un gouvernement
les premiers jours de juin
la question du vote de confiance
pourrait les avait deux bornes
les mesures sur le pouvoir d'achat mais
aussi la stratégie du rassemblement
national voilà beaucoup de thèmes à
aborder tout de suite pour notre premier
débat politique avec joséphine staron
bonjour bienvenue vous êtes directrice
des études et des relations
internationales du cercle de réflexion
sinopia laure salvaing bonjour bienvenue
vous êtes directrice générale de kantar
public j'accueille allemand fait les
potiers bonjour et bienvenue jour est
associé à la fondation jean jaurès et je
cite toujours votre ce thriller
politique falloir que je le lise avant
la fin de la saison quand même la menace
732 c'est aux éditions de l'aube mathieu
croissandeau éditorialiste politique
bienvenue à vous aussi mathieu peut-être
une question générale joséphine staron
comment vous jugez l'action d'elisabeth
board alors pas depuis sa nomination
mais depuis le 19 juin c'est à dire
depuis ce soir de séisme politique c'est
pas évident pour elle on est dans un
entre deux aujourd'hui et j'imagine que
pour la première ministre c'est pas
évident de jongler entre les
incertitudes qui sont celles d'emmanuel
macro aujourd'hui puisque il doit faire
face un parlement divisé en tout cas pas
en sa faveur
autant qu'il l'aurait souhaité et de
l'autre côté des oppositions qui m'a
jouent le jeu qu'elles doivent jouer le
rôle qu'elles doivent incarner
c'est-à-dire de d'essayer de mettre en
avant leur sujet lors problématique tout
en ayant leurs petites querelles
internes on l'a vu aux tout débuts avec
l'as du ps et on vous dira sur tous les
fronts pardon nous interrompt la haye le
moine le sentiment qu'elle me donne
c'est que elle occupe de plus en plus
quand même intérêt médiatique et
politique est très c'est ce sur quoi on
l'attendait et d'ailleurs emmanuel
macron en lui demandant de recevoir les
présidents de groupe toute cette semaine
est de former un nouveau gouvernement
d'ici juillet il lui donne cette cette
stature ce rôle politique qu'elle est
censée avoir de toute manière en tant
que premier ministre finalement on
l'attendait là pour l'instant elle ne
déçoit pas
mais tout tout tout va se décanter dans
les prochains jours ou les prochaines
semaines ce qui est certain c'est que
cet entre deux ce statu quo ne peut pas
durer elle le sait emmanuel macron le
sait et maintenant on attend l'éventuel
remaniement voire tout nouveau
gouvernement et laure salvaing la
première mini sont l'a déjà dit et dans
cette émission elle est un faible niveau
de confiance dans l'opinion est ce que
vous diriez que les français ils sont
sont hostiles ou plutôt attentistes en
fait je pense qu'ils sont plutôt
attentistes et finalement elle a pas
trop imprimer sa marque elizabeth bornes
dans le premier quinquennat macron quand
on interroge les français peu se
souviennent des mesures qu'elle aurait
porté et c'est ce qui reste en terme
d'image c'est son image de sérieux de
professionnels et de travailleuses et là
je crois d'ailleurs qu'elle illustre
bien effectivement cette image quelle
opinion d'elle mais en effet il n'ya pas
de deux il n'y a pas d'engouement n'y a
pas eu de surprise
quand on a annoncé la nomination
d'elizabeth borne pas d'arguments pas
surprise mais pas de rejet non plus
quand on regarde aussi son son image
selon les sympathies partisane il n'y a
pas de crispation d'un côté comme de
l'autre elle est perçue comme une femme
plutôt du centre voilà elle est pas
politiquement marqués on va le voir
d'ailleurs dans les prochains jours
puisque nous avons des baromètres
politiques qui vont sortir voilà je
pense qu'il y aura pas deux il y aura
pas de grande surprise aura pas
d'effondrement de son image pour le
moment elle est plutôt sable et
effectivement les français attendent de
voir ce que ce que ça va donner frick
poutine on a vu la scène au derrière les
abbés de banc de recevoir le soutien de
ses de ces mini c'est à gérald darmanin
qui disait elle est courageuse hier
aujourd'hui c'est oui via grégoire la
porte par le gouvernement qui elle n'est
pas isolée alors j'entends sage et puis
encore je me dis c'est un site de
faiblesse est ce que vous le faites est
ce que vous le lisez comme ça vous
d'abord il ya un espèce de temps mort
qui là puisqu'on attend un remaniement
dans un nouveau gouvernement il faut
quand même bien occupé le terrain donc
le petit de votre sujet était
parfaitement bien choisis et la ministre
c'est aussi la chef de la majorité donc
un peu pas non plus ne pas faire de
politique est effectivement que des
poids lourds du gouvernement rappelle
leur soutien c'est important à un moment
aussi il ya des tractations importante
et on va en parler une à l'assemblée
nationale ouais c'est clair que c'est le
signe qu'elle est attaquée en fait on
peut aussi le dire comme ça tout
simplement celle ci nq elle est attaquée
ou en tout cas qu'il ya des
interrogations sur sa capacité à agir
matthieu croissandeau comment comment
vous lisez les premiers pas d'elisabeth
borne est ce qu'on n'a pas été un peu un
peu dur dans l'est dans les tout
premiers jours où est ce que finalement
elle n'a pas été placée devant une
espèce de ce que vous disiez de dada
d'impossibilité par les choix qui ont
été faits par emmanuel macron 7,7 me
sont tardives cet homme sont pas
forcément été aidé de façon faut se
rappeler qu'elle a été nommée
extrêmement tardivement que la presse
s'est fait l'écho que c'était un
deuxième choix est pas le premier choix
du président qu'elle a composé son
gouvernement un moment où celui ci ne
pouvaient plus s'exprimer puisqu'on est
dans la période dite de réserve volé les
élections législatives pas évident
existants et sachant que à l'elysée on
avait un président qui à l'époque avait
tous les pouvoirs là encore aujourd'hui
oui mais peut-être plus autant et qui
décider de tout y compris du tempo de la
campagne y compris des messages de la
campagne y compris des adversaire à
désigner donc existé jusqu'au 19 juin ça
n'était pas évident et puis il faut
rappeler qu'elle avait aussi une
législative a gagné ce qu'elle a fait et
elle a remporté sa première tentative
d'élections dans le calvados et donc il
faut le saluer depuis elle a vécu une
semaine juste après très compliqué aussi
puisque son avenir était en suspens 18
ans la chef de la majorité qu'elle l'est
puisque lé premier ministre avait perdu
la majorité absolue elle ne bénéficiait
plus que d'une majorité relative tout le
monde s'interrogeait sur son futur son
avenir y compris dans son propre camp
françois bay on disait maintenant il
faut plutôt un profil politique le
président la république lui-même en
parlant devant les français ne
mentionnait pas son nom comme si elle
n'existait pas comme si elles
n'existaient plus donc allez allez
exister politiquement avec ça et puis
tout d'un coup à la boum voilà en une en
une soirée de samedi soir la voile à
confirmer dans la durée d'une présidence
enfin ça va ses promesses qui n'engagent
que ceux qui les écoutent avec pour
mission de composer un gouvernement est
de mener la politique donc on n'est
jamais que mercredi en trois jours elle
a reçu les chefs des différents groupes
à l'assemblée nationale elle ne regarde
qu'elle peut faire pour son gouvernement
et puis elle commence à délivrer des
messages politiques on va pas lui ça a
démarré très lentement ça n'était pas
entièrement de sa faute est aujourd'hui
et a un côté rattrapage c'est pas
suffisant pour imprimer une marque c'est
pas su prison pour fixer un cap il va
falloir du temps mais les français vont
en prendre à mon avis à découvrir
elisabeth bande qui a les qualités que
vous avez souligné c'est une femme
travailleuse oui encore eux ont
peut-être aussi qu' une bonne maîtrise
de ces dossiers ce qui n'est pas
toujours donné à tous les politiques
c'est quelqu'un vraiment pire qu'il y
des dossiers de a à z et puis c'est
quelqu'un qui est opiniâtre c'est
quelqu'un qui est tenace et ça ce sont
des qualités qui à mon avis vont
l'asservir faut pas la sous-estimer ce
n'est pas peut-être pas une grande
politique avec un passé fait de de
négociations entre politique mais elle a
fait les négociations avec les
partenaires sociaux et puis le fait
qu'elle soit pas non plus impersonnel un
personnage politique de premier plan
avec des ambitions assumer peut aussi la
servir parce que c'est peut-être plus
facile de discuter ou de voter pour un
texte présenté par un gouvernement dont
la chef n'a pas une ambition dévorante
en visant par exemple en 2027 une forme
de neutralité qui peut être en tout cas
perçu comme tel et qui peut lui
permettre d'aller chercher des soutiens
à gauche ou à droite est est ce qu elle
va s qu'elle doit se soumettre un vote
de confiance mais on va déjà lui donner
la parole à elle la première ministre on
écoute elisabeth bande je consulte les
différents groupes parlementaires ces
consultations elles sont en cours tous
que c'est un sujet tout
freches je veux pas faire tous les
développements sur le sens de le faire
ou de ne pas le faire mais donc je
prendrai ma décision à l'issue des
consultations
décision de crise donc voilà un sujet
qui mérite qu'on y réfléchisse voilà pas
de décision de prise quand un calme mais
vous pouvez nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau pour pour nous expliquer ce qui
s'est passé et ce qui a jeté le trouble
sur ce thème c'est la publication au
journal officiel du décret de
convocation du parlement en juillet et
justement c'est un passage obligé
lorsque l'été arrive le présent implique
qu'ils convoquent les députés et des
sénateurs pour siéger il donne au
passage le programme des textes qui
seront examinées on voit les textes donc
sur le pouvoir d'achat c'est attendu la
crise sanitaire est également le projet
de loi de finances rectificative c'est
habituel à ce moment là de l'année et
avant tout cela vous voyez en haut de la
page on lit également qu'une déclaration
du gouvernement est bien prévu devant
l'assemblée nationale sauf qu'il n'ya
aucune mention d'un vote de confiance ce
qui a fait dire aux observateurs que
l'exécutif comptait s'en passer faux
rétorque le gouvernement écoute et
olivier grégoire ce matin
il n'est pas spécifié dans le décret
qu'il y aura vote de confiance on n'a
pas spécifié il n'est pas écrit n'est
pas fait mention de l'article 10 49 qui
stipule qu'il y aurait un vote de
confiance mais je vais être très clair
ce matin ça n'est pas parce que ça n'est
pas inscrit dans le décret que la
première miss ne pourrait pas le faire
aucune porte n'est fermée et au moment
où je vous parle ce vote de confiance
est tout à fait possible elle n'a pas
pris cette décision et c'est à elle de
la première il avait deux bornes et qui
attend en fait la fin des rencontres
avec les différents leaders politiques à
matignon pour se décider au sénat le lr
roger karoutchi croit savoir qu'elle
pourrait choisir la position la plus
risquée écouter l'ancien ministre des
relations avec le parlement sous nicolas
sarkozy
apparemment il y aura un vote ce qui je
pense est liée aux consultations on a vu
que tous les groupes d'opposition
demandent est-ce qu' un vote
que donc est ce que finalement ils se
disent par brad prenons le risque
d'avoir un vote en se disant peut-être
que certains députés en tout cas d'abord
dès l'abord de cette déclaration ne
voudront pas ruiner l'institution votant
non d'office ce aux sénateurs qui
explique ce soir ndlr qui détiendront la
clé du scrutin car la nuque et le haut
pérenne vont s'abstenir et bien la
simple abstention du groupe et l'air
pourrait suffire à elisabeth bornes
écouter la suite groupe doit être assez
partagés certains doivent dire non on
dit non d'office d'autres doivent dire
attendons au moins de savoir ce qu'il ya
dans le texte de déclaration de
politique générale pour décider du vote
mais je ne sais pas je n'ai pas décidé à
la place de nos collègues députés ils
vont y vont de toute façon se réunir
mardi matin c'est à dire avant la
déclaration c'est peut-être 14 madame
bornes tu vas attendre la fumée blanche
du groupe a l'air à l'assemblée
nationale mardi matin voilà suspense
suspense mais l'enjeu est grand il
rappelle que si ils avaient deux bornes
décide donc de se soumettre à un vote
mais qu'elle n'a pas la majorité est
bien devra quitter matignon
effectivement la nuque et le groupe et
rennes qui ont voté contre il est
évidemment un petit lapsus merci
beaucoup quentin josephine staton la
première ministre peut-elle gouverner
longtemps je parle pas forcément
seulement du 5 juillet mais gouverner
longtemps sans demande sans se soumettre
à ce vote de confiance à un moment ou un
autre en fait le problème que ça soulève
c'est la question des légitimités
d'elisabeth bornes mais c'est pas
forcément sa légitimité à elle qui est
en question à travers elle c'est celle
du président emmanuel macron et de son
élection que beaucoup notamment les deux
oppositions
juge comme n'étant pas une adhésion par
une élection d'adhésion mais de rejet
des deux extrêmes et ça se voit ça se
voit bien aux gens depuis avec la
composition de l'assemblée locale
isabelle borne elle est prise dans cette
question de la légitimité du de
l'exécutif finalement donc est ce
qu'elle peut gouverner longtemps sans
s'y soumettre c'est difficile parce que
dès le lendemain des élections
législatives du second tour les
oppositions ont appelé à ce vote de
confiance en sachant très bien qu'ils
voudraient voter contre et qu'il
voudrait donc renverser le gouvernement
et chacun se voit premier ministre à la
place de la première ministre actuel
donc elle peut difficilement y échapper
mais là où peut-être que le sénateur
karoutchi a raison c'est que
ça arrivera finalement deux trois quatre
semaines après les élections
législatives dans un climat peut-être un
petit peu plus calme qu au lendemain ce
qui permettrait effectivement à certains
députés de se dire que leur
responsabilité est de confirmer ce
gouvernement en tout cas pour un temps
pour un temps défini sachant que rien ne
sera définitif
lors sa place que vous avez testé cette
question du vote de confiance auprès de
l'opinion pour les français ou est-ce
que ça passe un peu loin des radars on
va dire alors on n'a pas testé mais j'ai
quand même regardé si nos confrères
l'avait testé et figurez-vous que
viennent de tester les labos nos
confrères hélas bien de le tester sept
français sur dix
souhaiterez ce vote de confiance alors
il faut évidemment expliquer aux
français à quoi sert ce vote de
confiance aussi parce que si on parle
juste de vote de confiance comme ça
c'est c'est pas évident je pense surtout
que s'il n'avait pas lieu les français
seraient très ans très en colère y'a pas
effectivement d'enjeux majeurs pour ce
vote de confiance le sénateur
l'expliquer il suffit qu'il ya des
abstentionnistes et finalement elle
aurait
son vote sans vote de confiance en
revanche si elle ne le faisait pas si
elle ne le proposait pas ou si elle ne
le souhaitait pas là ça serait un signe
vraiment très négatif à l'égard de
l'opinion française alors même qu'ils
ont souhaité qu' il ait une diversité à
l'assemblée nationale finalement ça
serait un premier signe de bonne non je
ne considère pas cette diversité je ne
mets pas en avant devant cette diversité
et je crois par ailleurs que les
différentes oppositions ont montré ces
derniers jours aussi en tout cas
certains députés qu'il souhaitait
justement
compter dans le jeu politique pas
seulement dans l'opposition de principe
de base je crois que les français
justement souhaite condé veut qu'on
dépasse 7 cette opposition de base mais
plutôt une opposition constructive
effectivement qui est très attentiste
comme on l'a dit sur elisabeth bornes et
son gouvernement fall est petit on peut
peut-être évoqué ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée elle vote pour
le questeur des vice-présidences à
étayer une sorte de biya de jeu de
billard à trois bandes où tout le monde
n'a pas voté comme on pouvait s'y
attendre c'est un peu ça il ya eu
plusieurs étapes 1 dans les questions
politiques et les votes ce qui était
extrêmement important l'assemblée sol
d'abord il ya eu l'élection au perchoir
à la présidence de heilbronn pub et ça
c'était attendu elle a été élue dès le
deuxième tour de scrutin alors qu'elle
aurait pu l'être troisième parce que
justement les députés à l'assemblée
nationale ont retiré leur candidat et
donc ça c'est déjà un signe de
responsabilité et de volonté
d'apaisement du débat démocratique ils
deux autres élections importantes les
vice présidents et des questeurs alors
pour ceux qui nous regardent les
questeurs c'est ce qu'ils font marcher
l'assemblée nationale et décide des
dépenses il dessine aussi d'affecter des
ressources donc c'est c'est important
parce qu'il ya que trois questeurs et
souvent il y en a deux pour la majorité
un pour l'opposition est donc là il ya
eu il ya eu un deal politique et essai
ricciotti des républicains qui a obtenu
ce poste extrêmement important de
questeur et d'une homérique entre
inquiet qui entre la majorité et l air
l'abstention probable du rassemble
nationale qui lui s'est rattrapé entre
guillemets sur des postes de vice
présidents il y avait six postes de
vice-président à pouvoir la majorité
présidentielle en obtenu que 2 la nuque
on a obtenu
2 oc & c leurs ascendants nationale qui
a obtenu les deux autres postes donc est
ce qu'il ya une forme de yalta
parlementaire entre les différentes
formations politiques ou est ce que
c'est encore plus compliqué que ça avec
des renvois d'ascenseur est bien le
dernier rendent ça va être probablement
l'élection et le vote de confiance
peut-être le 5 juillet mais avec
peut-être jeu les sims avant un poker
menteur parce que
si si elle prend le risque de demander
la confiance c'est effectivement en
imaginant peut être une abstention dlr
qui sait c'est rien n'est jamais dit et
d'ailleurs on l'a vu avec ces élections
législatives c'est la première fois dans
le cadre du quinquennat qu'un président
de la république n'obtient pas la
majorité
donc jusqu'à présent on était nombreux à
dire que le quinquennat ne favorisait
pas ce type de législature finalement
c'était possible donc là aussi tout est
possible la première ministre prend un
risque même si ce risque sera calculée
même si forcément dans les entretiens
qu'elle mène en ce moment avec les
présidents de groupe cette question est
posée cette question et négocier mais le
risque est là il existe toujours et donc
qu'est ce qu'il se passerait si
effectivement elle devait démissionner
de son poste de premier ministre là je
pense que non seulement emmanuel macron
seraient embêtés pour retrouver
quelqu'un mais les oppositions aussi
parce que pour tomber d'accord sur une
nouvelle personnalité avec cette
nouvelle composition de l'assemblée
nationale ce sera extrêmement compliqué
est extrêmement long donc finalement le
choix de maintenir elisabeth bornes
serait peut-être le choix le plus
prudent dans la tête de nombreux députés
alors combien manque t-il de députés
c'est d'une certaine façon officielle
depuis que les listes ont été publiées
au journal officiel du groupe politique
dont sept groupes d'opposition et la
majorité présidentielle affiche 250
députés donc on est à 39 voix de la
majorité absolue
donc il ya déjà eu mathieu un certain
nombre de 2 entre guillemets de
débauchage sait pas forcément ce
débauchage des députés qui sont qui
n'est pas forcément élu sous une
étiquette politique qui sont inscrits ça
arrive parfois dans les territoires
d'outre-mer ou qui sont toujours l'objet
d'une grande convoitise la part des
groupes qui ont besoin de compléter leur
effectif quand ils sont un peu trop peu
nombreux mais voilà il peut y avoir des
deux non inscrits qui restent non
inscrits il y en a encore d'autres qui
rejoint des petits groupes donc voilà
c'est ce qui a permis en fait emmanuel
macron de parler d'une trentaine de voix
qui lui manquait ce qu'est un chiffre
qui avait surpris tout le monde parce
que sur le papier ils ont manqué 43 au
soir du du 19 de 19 juin alors 39 c'est
presque 40 mais on peut encore parler
d'une trentaine c'est pas facile à
trouver quand même 1 39 voix c'est faut
aller les chercher alors il y aura sans
doute c'est ce qu'a été en tout cas
expliqué par les abbés de bord n'est pas
réparé macron gaza sera texte par texte
1 puisque là c'est difficile de trouver
un partenaire de coalition comme ça se
fait ailleurs à l'étranger donc ça sera
texte par texte c'est pas un faisable il
y aura sans doute moins de lois mais ça
va être plus compliqué et sa foi et sa
force d'une façon à une forme la version
heureux c'est que ça force à une forme
de compromis démocratique et compromis
républicains comme ça peut se passer
ailleurs la version négative c'est si
c'est juste du débauchage et des
accointances entre tel ou tel pour pour
faire passer une loi oui et puis un
autre élément est un peu des deux puis
un autre élément on avait un débat sur
ce thème hier dans cette émission sur
justement la culture du compromis et de
la coalition chez nos voisins européens
il ya un autre risque et le risque du
plus petit dénominateur commun il se
retrouvait finalement avec des textes un
peu on va dire faiblard en termes de
d'ambitions politiques et d'ambition de
deux réformes je vous propose d'écouter
on va parler effectivement de ces
majorités au cas par cas texte par texte
je vous propose d'écouter sur ce thème
le ministre clément bonne nous sommes la
force centrale notre adn politique c'est
le rassemblement et de dépassements
c'est pas des mots qui sont des slogans
on a l'éclat pratique aujourd'hui donc
on va devoir discuter pour trouver une
majorité avec des gens responsables
soucieux des finances publiques soucieux
de justice sociale moi je souhaite qu'on
puisse le faire avec les socialistes des
écologistes constructif comme avec des
gens ce que j'entends
joséphine staron c'est intéressant parce
qu'on est dans la feuille de route
donnée par le présent la république à
elisabeth board c'est à dire alors il
n'a pas cité le parti communiste mais du
parti communiste aux élèves voilà le
voilà le champ politique dans lequel et
les alliances sont possibles selon
présent dans quel état la journaliste
avant d'être coupé mais en même temps
moi aussi ça me ça me fait tout de suite
penser à ça mais il n'a pas d'autre
choix aujourd'hui il doit composer alors
c'est difficile pour lui d'imaginer à
aller chercher des soutiens du côté des
les filles ou du r'n parce que les
positions sont radicalement différents
ont été opposés sur un certain nombre de
sujets mais en revanche avec d'autres et
notamment des du parti socialiste ou dlr
il peut trouver certains compromis sur
certains textes mais je voudrais revenir
sur ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
c'est est ce que dans ce nouveau
gouvernement de coalition de compromis
qu'on connaît bien en europe qu on
connaît moins bien en français ce qu'on
arrivera à des réformes d'envergure
toute la campagne présidentielle a été
question de ces grandes réformes à mener
pour sauver le pays pour transformer le
pays bien aujourd'hui ça va être très
compliqué parce que réussir à mettre
tout le monde d'accord ou en tout cas
une vraie majorité d'accord sur des
textes importants devraient
transformation c'est le challenge
aujourd'hui et on va le voir dès cet été
avec le projet sur le pouvoir d'achat
alors il ya il ya une double analyse de
du résultat du du 19 juin il ya ceux qui
disent la france s'est fracturé c'est la
démonstration que la france est facturé
et ceux qui disent ben ont finalement
une sorte d'intelligence collective des
français qui veulent que les partis
politiques s'entendent comme dans quel
camp entre guillemets à ça moi je
parlerais pas forcément de fractures je
parle de diversité en fait la france est
diverse et et
l'image de l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui finalement elle est à
l'image aussi de l'état d'esprit des
français c'est-à-dire qu'elle est
composée de plusieurs forces politiques
et on voit bien en fait depuis plusieurs
années les français nous demandent dans
les études que nous pouvons faire de ce
qui l'attend c'est justement de pouvoir
composer et d'être un peu au cas par cas
quand il nous parle aussi de leurs
souhaits à l'égard des institutions de
des services publics y parle beaucoup de
personnalisation c'est on veut des
services personnalisés voilà c'est un
peu ça aussi on veut pouvoir discuter au
cas par cas peut-être prendre des idées
aussi à droite parfois l'extrême droite
parfois l'extrême gauche je parlais tout
à l'heure d'un sondage et lab ils ont
également posé la question de savoir si
les français souhaitait qu'il y ait des
membres de dans le gouvernement dans le
futur gouvernement des membres de est du
rnd d'europe écologie les verts et deux
des républicains vous avez à peu près
50% des français qui disent oui ce
serait bien qu'ils aient des
représentants de des écologistes et de l
air en premier dans le nouveau
gouvernement mais vous avez aussi 41%
des français qui nous disent pas ce
serait bien aussi qu'il y ait des
représentants du rassemblement national
donc vous voyez je pense que les parle
pas de fracture mais tu as diversité
effectivement les choses sont en train
de bouger aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de de
cristallisation très forte en tout cas
aussi forte qu'on a pu la voir par le
passé contre un camp contre un autre les
français sont persuadés qu'il ya des
bonnes idées à prendre un peu à droite
et à gauche et free potier est ce que
c'est cette ce discours-là sur
l'intelligence collective le message que
les français ont envoyé aux partis
politiques c'est pas un peu la musique
qu'ils avaient de banc d'essai ministre
joue pour inciter des députés allaient à
les rejoindre ah si c'est la condition
de survie dessus également cette fois
faire passer des textes par exemple sous
pouvoir d'achat mais il ya d'autres
textes quand ça l'immigration ou la
sécurité on voit bien qu'on pourrait
avoir un deal entre eux l heure gérald
darmanin d'autres membres du
gouvernement pour pousser ce texte là
qui devrait passer à 10 ans énormes
difficultés ni à l'assemblée nationale
ni au sénat par contre sur d'autres
textes on peut effectivement imaginer
que le gouvernement espère essayer de
pioche est comme ça et essayer sur
l'écologie développement durable essayer
d'aller tirer à soi des majorités
n'empêche que les partis politiques je
parle plus des français là mais des
partis politiques eux mêmes est-ce
qu'ils ont si intérêt que ça à faire
durer ce jeu de débauchage mais qui dit
ça c'est pas évident je pense qu'on peut
avoir une première phase où on se
regarde on se jauge est peut-être que
dans six mois certains s'y feront la fin
de la récré mais mes parts on aime aimer
mais c'est aussi à quel moment on
négocie contenu du texte c'est ça le
plus important non parce que et ça c'est
pas du tout dans une culture politique
c'est à dire que cissé
visa des deux bornes ou soul ou tel
ministre qui arrivent en disant voilà ça
c'est notre texte et puis bon bah
finalement décidé vous ça marchera pas
alors qui souvent que le parlement c'est
le coeur de la démocratie bien leur
manager illustrations très concrète
c'est à dire que en commission les
députés vont vraiment débattre avec le
gouvernement et ont vraiment pouvoir
proposer des amendements pour modifier
les textes et ça va plus seulement ceux
négociés dans les couloirs des
ministères entre la majorité et les
gouvernements et les ministres et ça
c'est plutôt une bonne chose va
réapprendre ce qu'est un régime
parlementaire j'ouvre un nouveau
chapitre dans ce débat sur la stratégie
du rassemblement national mathieu
vouliez revenir sur cette polémique
déclenchée à part les propos du député
rassemblement national josé gonzalez
hier lors de son discours de doyen à
l'assemblée oui parce qu'il aura suffi
au fond de quelques larmes d'un d'un
papy l'extrême droite au perchoir pour
contrarier la rentrée police et du
rassemblement national au palais bourbon
on résume si vous voulez bien depuis son
score inattendu
dimanche 19 juin au soir marine le pen
selon ses mots a opté pour une stratégie
d'opposition républicaine ferme
responsable et respectueuse institutions
mais toujours constructives en gros aux
autres le bruit et la fureur son
objectif à elle pour cette législature
c'est moins de s'opposer que de ceux
respectabiliser histoire montrer aux
français que non et rennes est devenu un
parti de gouvernement n'en déplaise à
benoît kron qui considère que ce n'est
pas le cas et que ses membres seraient
prêts à prétendre aux plus hautes
responsabilités alors sur l'effort le
message sur la forme par dont le message
a été passé à ces troubles de porter une
cravate vous avez vu la culture paquets
de nouilles et tee shirt de foot non
merci dit marine le pen j'ai laissé ça
rufin et odza d'isoler les fils à 100
ses mots
dans les médias sur les plateaux les
nouveaux députés rassemblement national
explique sans cesse qu'ils voteront tout
ce qui va dans l'intérêt des français ne
se prêteront pas au jeu stérile selon
eux d'une motion de censure promise par
notamment la france a soumise après la
déclaration de politique générale si
jamais il y avait un vote de confiance
il ya encore on en parlait sébastien
chenu a retiré dès le deuxième tour sa
candidature au perchoir en jugeant que
c'était encore inutile de faire durer un
faux suspense bref le rn jouer
tranquillement la carte de la
responsabilité quand soudain abbas
farhan haq est-ce que ça passe ce député
des bouches du rhône josé gonzalez donc
qui était le doyen de l'assemblée c'est
pour ça au titre de doyen qui présidait
là la première séance il se met à parler
de l'algérie française dans son discours
ce symbole d'unité touche l'enfant d'une
france d'ailleurs que je suis arraché à
sa terre natale et drossé sur les côtes
de provence alpes par le vent de
l'histoire 1962 j'ai laissé là bas une
partie de ma france et beaucoup d'amis
je suis un homme qui a vu son âme à
jamais meurtries
excusez moi je pense à mes amis j'ai
laissé là bas
je suis un homme qui a vu son âme à
jamais meurtries par le sentiment
d'abandon et les périodes de
déchirements
alors là on se dit qu'est ce que ça
vient faire là c'est totalement
déplacées et propre aux nostalgiques
d'un vieux monsieur de 79 ans mais pas
si sûr parce que interrogé peu après
dans la salle des quatre colonnes
l'assemblée il en a remis une couche
écoutez les crimes en algérie dans
l'armée française je ne pense pas
ils soir mais je ne pense pas et encore
moins un crime contre l'humanité
franchement je ne suis pas là pour juger
si l'ouest aco décline je sais même pas
où on se dit que c'est une arme du papy
paraissent bien moins émouvante du coup
un carlo et son rappel fut bien une
organisation terroriste
politico-militaire qui ensanglanta
l'algérie et la métropole à coups
d'attentats et d'assassinats qui firent
ont près de 2700 victimes et comme il
semble avoir la mémoire qui flanche josé
gonzalez on va lui rappeler aussi que l'
os a fourni un certain nombre de cadres
au front national au moment de sa
création en 1972 dans le plus célèbre
d'entre eux fut sans conteste roger
holeindre qui en fut longtemps vice
président de ce front national là en
gros le front national devenu
rassemblement national entre temps a
toujours été un refuge où un foyer de
nostalgiques de l'algérie française le
week-end dernier encore il se
réunissaient à perpignan la ville de
louis aliot pour célébrer entre autres
honorer la mémoire des putschistes
d'alger bref vous l'aurez compris faire
peau neuve n'empêche pas d'avoir de
vieilles racines et parfois toujours
bien vivace rappel dont marine le pen ce
serait évidemment bien passé un front
national gentil ça n'intéresse personne
et les républicains et les centristes
pour ça c'est jean marie le pen qui
l'avait dit à quelques mois après la
défaite de sa de sa fille à la
présidentielle de
2017 joséphine star en est ce que vous
direz c'est encore vrai aujourd'hui
cette phrase de jean marie le pen je
pense pas que ce soit une question de
gentils ou de méchants si on pense qu'on
en est encore la flambée en vigueur
résumait vérité derrière mais on
comprend le radical
1re assemblée nationale qui serait
toujours très radicales
pour jean marie le pen c'est voilà c'est
son adn selon lui mais c'est pas du tout
l'adn de marine le pen en tout cas ça ne
l'est plus depuis un certain temps
depuis 2010 est et on l'a vu tout au
long de la campagne présidentielle où
elle a laissé finalement à eric zemmour
toute la partie un peu radical sur les
questions de sécurité les questions
d'immigration les questions identitaires
pour s'intéresser à la question du
pouvoir d'achat à l'économie et
finalement aux préoccupation première
des français donc là est là elle a bien
joué
effectivement quand on voit le ce député
est reine qui fait ça sont son discours
sur l'algérie française ça nous rappelle
à tous l'ancien fn l'ancien front
national est bien évidemment qu'il reste
encore cette génération qui a qui a
fondé ce front national aux côtés de
jean-marie le pen et qu'il garde qu'ils
gardent leurs idées leurs idéologies
mais il ya aussi toute une nouvelle
franche toute une nouvelle génération
au rassemblement national sur laquelle
mise marine le pen on pense à jordan
bardella mais il y en a d'autres
aujourd'hui qui sont députés à
l'assemblée nationale et forcément c'est
un tout nouveau visage que cette
génération-là veut montrer vous l'avez
dit c'est un parti de gouvernement
qu'ils veulent incarner aujourd'hui
alors le pourront-ils le frontil ça
c'est une autre question mais c'est la
stratégie de marine le pen ça l'était
déjà au moment des présidentielles ça
l'est encore aujourd'hui et puis laure
salvaing on peut dire que les derniers
scrutins que ce soit la présidentielle
ou là combien législatives ben firme
ce ce supposé france national gentil qui
n'intéresse personne absolument je pense
qu'une démonstration par les urnes quoi
tout simplement sasson par les urnes et
puis démonstration aussi dans l'opinion
des français qui expriment ces derniers
temps finalement le sentiment que le
rassemblement national c'est des
extraits misé que et ils sont de plus en
plus d'accord aussi avec les positions
du front national sur un certain nombre
du rassemblement national sur un certain
nombre de sujets et finalement que le
rassemblement national représente -
danger pour la démocratie c'est une
question que nous suivons depuis les
années 80
- un danger pour la démocratie qu'avant
voyons aujourd'hui à peu près 40% des
français qui considèrent que leur
enseignement national est un danger pour
la démocratie
c'était 25 points de plus il y a un au
stress que une dizaine d'années dont
vous voyez il ya aussi un décalage entre
ce que pense l'opinion
ce qu'incarnent aujourd'hui marine le
pen et puis les différents dirigeants du
rassemblement national et puis ce que
pense évidemment jean marine le pen qui
est dansé dansé clou je dirais pas de
surprise ferrique potier le le vote ou
non de la motion de censure pas le
rassemblement national ce serait quand
même un premier révélateur intéressant
oui alors là qu'ils ont des ressources
et qu'il a déposé cette motion de
censure parce que si la bête bornes ne
se soumet pas à cette motion de 7,7 ce
vote de confiance mardi mardi
jean-luc mélenchon a d'ores et déjà
indiqué qu'ils auraient une motion de
censure donc en fait un vote en retour
et si à ce vote en retour de sanction il
est assez peu probable que les
différents groupes politiques là se
coalisent pour la voter parce que la
motion de censure elle est quand même
motivé il ya une expression qui justifie
pourquoi elle doit être votée et donc je
pense que les députés ni rennes ni
heller ne se prêteront à ce jour là
parce que il y aurait finalement peu
d'intérêt et il plongerait l'origine
dans une grave crise avec
potentiellement des élections
législatives horizon rapproché ce don à
mon avis ils n'ont pas intérêt donc
plutôt intérêt à laisser le gouvernement
se casser les dents sur les prochaines
échéances et éventuellement peut-être le
faire chuter plus tard j'aimerais qu'on
parle de pouvoir d'achat maintenant et
je vais citer le sondage est là pour
bfmtv dont vous parliez 78% des français
disent que la priorité c'est que
majorité et opposition se mettent
d'accord sur le pouvoir d'achat ça
rejoint finalement le le débat dont on
parlait
franchement sur ce texte là si la bête
bornes ne trouve pas de majorité ce sera
très mal parti joséphine star on le sera
mal voit mal les parties petit prendre
le risque d'aller contre cette demande
très forte et cette urgence même vécue
par les français lui il ment il y aura
très vraisemblablement un projet de loi
qui fera consensus en revanche ça
n'empêche pas que pour l'instant il dit
les défunts unis négocier puisqu'il ya
des points soulevés qui sont divergents
c'est le président du sénat gérard
larcher qui a rappelé qu' une des
grandes différences entre les l air et
la majorité c'était la manière dont on
envisage les dépenses publiques par
exemple puisque le fameux quoi qu'il en
coûte a souvent été reproché à emmanuel
macron à sa droite donc il va falloir qu
emmanuel macron et avec elisabeth bornes
trouve l'on va dire une solution à cette
équation difficile entre injecté des
milliards et des milliards pour
favoriser le pouvoir d'achat des
français et en même temps faire des
économies ce qui pour l'instant n'est
pas prévu parce qu'il n'ya pas de hausse
d'impôts demandé par la majorité ni ni
ni ni de hausse de la dette publique
donc on voit mal comment cette équation
pourra être résolu ou en tout cas il va
falloir il va falloir faire des
compromis jardin man 1 et bruno le maire
ont déjà exprimé leur inquiétude quant
aux à l'état des finances publiques ça
on les a entendus aujourd'hui hier je
crois ce qui montre bien qu' il y aura
peut-être que petit droitisation de ce
plan pouvoir d'achat pour compenser les
pertes alors justement c'est intéressant
sur ce thème d'écouté
gabriela talent ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics bref mini du budget
la main content c'est qu'on est prêt à
regarder toutes les mesures qui
permettent d'améliorer la protection des
français leur pouvoir d'achat mais qui
ne constituent pas des augmentations
d'impôts est ce que donner d'une main et
reprendre de l'autre ça n'a pas de sens
pour nous et qui ne dégrade pas et
n'alourdisse pas la dette sur les années
à venir parce que là il ya des impôts de
demain si je devais résumer un exemple
aux offices sur le pouvoir d'achat parce
que vous avez cité un certain nombre de
mesures ça fait peut-être un peu
beaucoup pour ceux qui nous écoutent on
veut permettre aux français de dépenser
moins et de gagner plus falek potier le
message est à destination des élèves oui
mais c'est pas gagné c'est pas facile à
faire parce que en économie et en
finances publiques a pas de baguette
magique y a pas de recette miracle donc
ne pas augmenter les impôts mais
injecter du pouvoir d'achat ça suppose
ou bien qu'on fait du redéploiement ça
veut dire qu'on va tailler dans les
dépenses publiques sauf que là on a eu
une augmentation des rémunérations des
fonctionnaires qui est engagée ça
suppose sinon que eh bien je sais pas
vraiment ya pas dix mille façons en fait
de tenir cette équation là donc je pense
que du côté de bercy les ministres sont
un peu sur le fil du rasoir entre ne pas
alourdir la dette ne pas augmenter les
impôts et trouver quand même des leviers
suffisant pour injecter de l'argent et
ça donne cette cette interview un peu
schizophrénique de bruno le maire cette
semaine d'un côté il dit la dette on est
à un niveau critique et de l'autre il
annonce quand même qu'on va continuer de
soutenir le pouvoir d'achat des français
est passé on voit bien un ministre et la
culture d'un ministre confronté au réel
et il le faire à court terme c'est ça
qui est encore plus difficile
d'ailleurs dans les annonces du jour il
ya la question du chèque alimentaire
olivier grégoire l'a confirmé le
gouvernement y réfléchit avec les
oppositions il pourrait bénéficier à
neuf millions de foyers les plus
modestes 100 euros par foyer 50 euros
par enfant laure salvaing dans cette
phrase c'est l'expression avec les
oppositions qui est peut-être la plus
importante
oui
avec les oppositions mais surtout ce qui
est important d'avoir en tête aussi
c'est que les français aujourd'hui ils
sont de plus en plus soucieux de la
dette qui a été créée de ce quoi qu'il
en coûte aussi
penser que c'est plus important dans
l'esprit des français que
mesure de pouvoir d'achat pour sortir
c'est pas plus important mais c'est
quand même dans la tête des français
c'est pour ça que c'est compliqué aussi
de créer de la dette publique parce
qu'il ya aussi cette souci pour les
générations à venir de finalement
comment on va rembourser tout ça et puis
je crois aussi que
dans la tête des français ce qui est
important c'est qu'ils ont toujours le
sentiment aussi qu'il ya finalement
d'autres qui pourraient payer avant que
soient les entreprises les grandes
entreprises ou alors les politiques ou
alors
les plus les plus comment dire ceux qui
profitent du système les profiteurs
voyez donc c'est compliqué aussi dans
l'opinion finalement de trouver une
solution pour défendre ce pouvoir
d'achat tout le sentiment finalement
qu'on peut prendre de l'argent ailleurs
plutôt que dans les caisses de l'état
directement sachant que les caisses de
l'état ne sont pas remplies et puis on
sort on l'a dit suffisamment de deux
années d'argent magique donc forcément
ça c'est ça s'appelle une drogue dure
mais si on va conclure avec vous ce
thème quand même de la dette tue pas
tout à fait d'accord avec vous est
totalement zappé de des campagnes
présidentielles et législatives en
parler et là il revient petit à petit
avec bono le maire qui dit attention la
cote d' alerte d'une certaine façon
valérie pécresse on avait parlé un peu
mais c'était bien la seule parce que la
campagne 2022 ne s'est pas fait sur les
finances publiques l'habitude c'est un
refrain très classique à droite quand on
fait toujours campagne sur les finances
publiques en disant il faut bien gérer
des dépenses obligatoires sur la gauche
et dépensière nous on est des bons pères
de famille et la dette la dette la dette
qui était un thème cher à françois
bayrou aussi on s'en souvient mais
aujourd'hui la dette elle est devenue
plus la dette écologique d'une certaine
façon que la dette financière les gens
se projette plus sur la le monde qu'on
laisse à nos enfants que sur les comptes
qu'on laisser à nos enfants mais dans la
majorité il ya des voix qui se font
entendre souvenez-vous d'edouard
philippe l'ordre dans la rue et dans les
fonds publics merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
rappelle le titre de votre livre cédric
pottier la menace
732 livre publié aux éditions de lot 2